[Music]
cosmologists
study the past using light just as
archaeologists
study the past using ruins so for
example
the light that comes from a star tells
us how it was back in the past
and the further away we look the further
away
we can look in time and so doing
cosmology is a way
of traveling to our past
[Music]
i use cosmological observations to try
to shed light on the dark sector
[Music]
this is a map of the cosmic microwave
background temperature fluctuations
here the different colors correspond to
different temperatures
and so the regions with more temperature
correspond to more matter
and these regions with more matter
grew because of gravity and form the
stars and galaxies that we observe today
with my research group at harvard we
have been using gravitational lensing in
order to map dark matter fluctuations at
small scales
we have been doing this in two ways one
is statistical
detection way in which we develop the
formalism
to link dark matter theories to length
scales and so this formalism helps us
understand dark matter
with very small masses i have been very
excited
to use machine learning techniques in
order to
see clamps that before people have not
been able to see
with direct detection techniques
[Music]
we will not be stuck if we don't find it
we will always
think about new possibilities and think
about ways
in which we could look for dark matter